nos preguntan cuántas ardillas hay nos
dan estas opciones pero vamos a cortar
las ardillas vamos a tener cuidado de no
contar dos veces la misma hebilla
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 ardillas seleccionamos esta
opción comprobamos nuestra respuesta
es correcta vamos a hacer otro problema
ahora nos preguntan cuántos pollitos hay
veamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 pollitos elegimos esta
porque hay 18 pollitos comprueba tu
respuesta es correcta hagamos otro
problema más cuantos mapaches ves a esta
distribución es interesante voy a
comenzar a contar a partir de este mapa
che de aquí hasta arriba y voy a cuidar
de no contarlo varias veces así que
comenzamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 9 mapaches
a lo mejor estoy tentada de contar este
pero me acuerdo que ya lo conté entonces
tenemos 9 mapaches seleccionamos este
comprobamos la respuesta
hagamos otro problema más cuántos
pingüinos ven nuevamente voy a
asegurarme de comenzar a contar a partir
de este pingüino de aquí arriba y no lo
voy a volver a contar otra vez es 1 2 3
4 5 no voy a hacer así contar 6 porque
este pingüino ya lo conté entonces nos
quedamos aquí 5 pingüinos elegimos esto
comprobamos respuesta es correcta